your surgeon may perform a
fundoplication to treat gastro
esophageal
phlex disease or to repair
hernia digestion begins in the mouth as
teeth break food into smaller pieces
saliva releases digestive enzymes when
food is swallowed it enters the
esophagus a long muscular tube that
carries food from the mouth to the
stomach for further digestion
contractions called
peristalsis push food down the esophagus
at the bottom of the esophagus food
passes through a muscular valve called
the lower esophageal sphincter or le s
and into the stomach the digestive juice
is secreted by the stomach our highly
acidic when the stomach contracts to
move the food into the intestine the le
s closes tightly in order to prevent
these acidic juices from moving back
into the esophagus where it can cause
damage a breathing muscle called the
diaphragm separates the chest from the
abdomen to reach the stomach the
esophagus passes through the diaphragm
at a point called the hiatal ring if you
have gastro esophageal reflux disease or
GERD your le s does not close properly
allowing acidic stomach contents to flow
backward into your esophagus
if GERD is not treated it can lead to a
variety of esophageal problems including
ulcers bleeding strictures or narrowings
and Barrett's esophagus which is the
abnormal growth of intestinal type cells
in the esophagus that can lead to cancer
if you have a hiatal hernia a portion of
your stomach is protruding into your
chest cavity through the opening in your
diaphragm a hiatal hernia can affect the
le s and increase the risk and severity
of GERD
to begin your procedure an IV line will
be inserted into your arm to provide
fluids and medication a catheter may be
placed into your bladder to drain urine
you will be given general anesthesia
which will put you to sleep for the
entire procedure once you're asleep a
breathing tube will be inserted through
your mouth and into your windpipe to
help you breathe during the operation
one of two methods may be used for a
fund application in the traditional open
procedure your surgeon will begin by
making an 8 inch incision in the abdomen
to expose the stomach and lower
esophagus after separating it from
nearby structures your surgeon will wrap
the fundus or upper part of the stomach
around the lower esophagus and stitch it
into place this wrap acts as a belt
which tightens and strengthens the le s
scopic procedure your surgeon will begin
by making five small keyhole incisions
each about 1/2 inch long in your abdomen
through one incision your surgeon will
insert the laparoscope which is a long
thin tube equipped with a light and a
camera the camera sends images to a
video screen for the surgeon to view gas
will be pumped in to inflate your
abdomen to enable the surgeon to see
your internal organs more clearly
through the other incisions your surgeon
will use instruments to detach the
fundus of your stomach from its
surroundings wrap it around your lower
esophagus and stitch it into place
if you have a hiatal hernia your surgeon
will pull the herniated part of the
stomach back into place in the abdomen
and tighten the hiatal ring in the
diaphragm to prevent another hernia this
can be done through either an open or
laparoscopic procedure to complete the
surgery the abdominal incisions are
closed with stitches or staples
when you awake from surgery you will
find a small tube passing through your
nose and into your stomach
this tube helps remove fluids and gas
from the site of the surgery and is
usually removed within 2 days you will
be encouraged to get out of bed and
begin walking the same day of surgery